if you like free stuff high fantasy and  owned an xbox one or xbox 360 then I  have some good news for you The Witcher  2 assassins of kings is free on xbox  live the game is free for both xbox one  and xbox 360 owners better yet you don't  even need an xbox live gold membership  to a demon Witcher 2 is made free  sometime before january twentieth and  the deal will continue until februari  5th the game normally costs thirty  dollars so even if you don't plan on  playing it anytime soon it might be  worth hitting that download button  anyway The Witcher 2 came out in 2011  for PC and follows the story of guralt a  monster slayer as he tries to clear his  name be warned though this chapter is a  little more challenging than the witcher  3 wild hunt for more on the witcher and  everything gaming stay tuned to gamespot